delay from my
end
please let me know
and also in turn if you are experiencing
any communication or
issues with your connection um i may
need to request that you terminate your
link
um but hopefully given that we've
already successfully held a meeting this
morning and everybody seems to
participate really well um i'm sure that
we can conduct this meeting
well
we have a clear with it
sorry uh madame chair i'd just like to
give notice that they'll be um asking
for a late item to be accepted
titan said
thank you
sure you wish it um
we've got a clear quorum this afternoon
as everybody is here aside from the
apologies of counsellor
kit councillor abbott and uh of course
jeff grant who's otherwise engaged
we have no public forum this afternoon
as of course this is unusual we're in
a zoo meeting
and we have uh two now three potentially
major late items um
to receive this afternoon one of them or
both of them have come from uh the risk
and assurance meeting this morning
uh held on 24th of august one is
relating to the terms of reference for
an independent review of electronic
access
the reason that the item was not on the
agenda was because the documents had
been received after the agenda had been
published
we need to discuss it this afternoon so
that it can be progressed in a timely
manner and the second item was uh
the
recommendation from rna risk insurance
this morning for the
annual report and insurance renewal um
as i've stated that only just happened
this morning but we need to discuss that
this afternoon to enable insurance
negotiations to continue within the
relevant time frame
uh can i have a mover and a secondary
for those two items
to be received as major late items i
could see councillor ludlow seconded
councillor sopa thank you very much for
that
all those in favor
aye aye
against
there's that pregnant pause i'm looking
for none against so that item is carried
we will now move on to
our agenda
do we have any declarations of interest
today
sorry madam chair um
his worship wanted a late time can we
deal with that as to whether or not it's
added
sure
what is your late item
your worship
um
it's item seven and
it's
suggesting that um
neither clear or her advisor should play
any role in choosing who conducts the
review
clear is um
implicated parties to the alleged and
properties of an email
uh the report
downplays fundamental
lack of consent by me
um this is referred to
but the term isn't
popular
but
it really
is suggesting a misuse
of an email and
it's a serious issue
um
i know that uh
people
feel
quite strongly about their privacy
or lack of it
and this is a manner of
dealing with those issues
you'll wish it our council has just now
uh resolved to
include the um in terms of reference for
that independent review you've just
referenced as part of our major lay item
process this afternoon so um
i
appreciate your want to have it have
your say on this topic so if it's okay
with you it's quite clear that it's
already in the agenda for discussion
this afternoon
and we will take that discussion at that
time uh under major items further along
in the agenda
thank you
councillor prodiger
was just asking why the mayor would want
the item race twice
when you've already stated that we are
doing that and it's come from risk and
assurance this morning so just curious
why the mayor wants to
double dip in this item
um
[Music]
i took advice on it at the time and um
i felt
the best way of dealing with it or and
what would help resolve
an issue like this
is to have it um
dead in
as a late item off
on the agenda and
uh neither
so that's
it was really
advice taking the time
um
thank you councillor sofa we will um
just move on from here
um and through into as i don't think we
had any declarations of interest just
going to call for that again
no no deflections of interest so we'll
move on to the minutes of the meeting of
council held on the 27th of july 2021
and we'll move that the minutes of those
be confirmed do i have a mover and
seconder for that
i'll move
nikki councillor sopa second councillor
keith
all those in favor
against
carrich
minutes of the extraordinary meeting of
infrastructural services committee held
on the 27th of july
we'll move that though
be received
yeah i will move that um
chair thank you council prodiger
seconder
i'll take in those
thank you thank you councillor lewis all
those in favor
aye aye
against
carrick
minutes of the infrastructural services
committee meeting held on the 3rd of
august 2021 be received
again i'll move those
second
second counselor sopa thank you all
there's a favor
minutes of the performance policy
partnerships committee held on the 10th
of august and within those there are a
couple of recommendations to council uh
15.2 for either that the clause um
15.1 of the invercargill venue and
events management limited ivan
constitution as set out below be changed
to a minimum of directors of two
so i'll move that the minutes received
and those recommendations adopted i
think in that
thank you councillor and bx our
councillor
sorry a monsoon
um
all those in favor
all right
thank you very much again
it is carried
and on to item eight minutes of the
extraordinary meeting out of council
held on the 10th of august 2021 and the
minutes be confirmed
move those
thank you council sopa
a bit of second thank you councillor
madison all those in favour
hi
thank you carriage
uh
minutes of the bluff community board
meeting held on the 16th of august 2021
move that those minutes uh be accepted
and i'd just like to draw everybody's
attention to item 9.4 which is the the
lack of communication by the icc towards
the bluff community board
thank you for that uh councillor sofa
and um julie noted councillor arnold i'm
sure that this council will want to
investigate further into that
uh all those in favor
excellent against
harriet
and item 10.
uh we have our governance statement 2019
22 uh august 21
2021 sorry amendment and we have michael
morris here today to talk to us about
why this needs to um happen to reflect
the recent governance changes
good afternoon madam chair your worship
and councillors uh thank you this is the
governance statement uh
changes made to this government
statement governance statement uh
reflecting the recent addition of the
manufuna rules to the two committees
and accordingly the governance statement
needed to be updated to give effect to
that so the report simply runs through
the small number of changes that we've
had
uh to make
uh to give effect to those roles and to
ensure that the rules are placed under
the uh code of conduct uh and standing
orders for debate and matters like that
so i'm there's not too much else uh to
this one so i'm quite happy as if i have
to take questions um
for that i do acknowledge the hard work
from uh talani she was going to be
sitting with me in the council chamber
today um
not able to do that because it's a
little hard when one's in a bubble uh
but i did want to acknowledge her hard
work
adam chair i'm happy to move the
happy
two
recommendations
you
guys
thank you councillor sofa and with the
note 2 that our council certainly shares
that sentiment um
michael that um thank you very much to
talini for
all of her hard work on this as well
um all those in favor or any discussion
i assumed so so
against
excellent uh that is carried
we'll move on now to item 11
which is the delegations register
and we have this afternoon
another report from michael morris
um hello again me again sorry i'm just
catching up on my um the agenda on my
phone um
a hard copy would have been really
useful for a document this size but
that's okay
so this is the delegations register
again
we've needed to make some changes to
reflect the uh recent edition of the
manufa seats but we've also taken this
opportunity to have a bit of a rethink
on how the delegations register is
presented
and you'll notice that we've now
essentially created two registers
the first is the council one and the
financial
delegations so this is um
approved by council which is why it's
here today the second register other is
simply the list of delegations from the
chief executive to staff to enable the
efficient running
of council
those delegations are only made by the
chief executive they don't need to be
approved by council and so that document
will go to the next executive leadership
meeting for
a confirmation but i just wanted to put
that out front
um
now so you know you're one not wondering
why the delegations register has um
been on a fairly significant weight loss
regime now the changes we've made to it
are
essentially to as i said give effect to
the monofinal receipts and then there
have been some corrections to the
financial delegations uh to make them
work a little more efficiently
and to provide a bit more clarity to
staff than where we were at
again um an enormous amount of work from
tulane on this document it is a beast of
a document and cut it into two has sort
of doubled her workload um so i'm
enormously grateful to her and as ever
happy to answer any questions
all right excellent
okay to move the through recommendations
madam chain thank you very much council
that lie happy the second again
thank you very much council sopa i'll
open that up for discussion
no everybody seems pretty happy with
that so i'll put the motion
all those in favor
bye
thank you against
tonight and that's carried
excellent
give me two seconds to get back to where
i was
it's not full versus technology thank
you very much um michael for that
excellent report and all of the teamwork
that's gone into bringing that forward
for us
uh next we're moving on to uh the urgent
business items which will treat uh
individually the first one that we had
uh pull through is the terms of
reference for the independent review of
electronic access
major light item now there has been a
minor amendment to what has been
presented in the public agenda this
afternoon um this morning at briscon
insurance meeting uh it was resolved
that
these recommendations went forward but
there were no amendments to the
recommendations so the recommendation as
it will read to be changed this
afternoon uh to take out be adopted with
any amendments
so the recommendation too will read that
the terms of reference for an
independent review of electronic access
attached as
appendix one
uh
there was be adopted with any
recommendations so we will remove that
um
sequence
because there were no recommendations i
think that that was clear
i think so
that need to be adopted
so we'll end it at be adopted um
because we no longer need with any
amendments uh to the risk and assurance
committee
so you'll be able to see there clear on
the screen
that it will end um
there and that end part will be removed
excellent
thank you very much for that so you'll
be able to see there clearly what we're
voting for
uh on the screen
happy to move those madam chairs
thank you happy the seconds madam chair
thank you very much councillor that's
right
and in doing so can i also comment just
to to point out that the report has come
from jane parfet um i noticed a point
that his worship was was trying to make
earlier about the chief executive's
involvement but the chief executive has
not written this report
and the um terms of reference have come
as you said from the risk and assurance
committee this morning
yes absolutely uh
both very um
astute points
now that we have had a move and a second
ear for that with councillor ludlow and
councillor sofa i will open it up for
discussion knowing that
the mayor his worship has already
indicated he would like to speak
so your worship now is your
time to do that
yes thank you
um
it's uh
an issue that's
as i said fundamental
requiring consent
for
a sensitive area of
our
work and operations that we undertake
and
so i
felt that
was that ideally
should come up uh yesterday
but um
it had to go through the
previous
um
meeting
for it to be accepted
for for to go
through the um
corrupt process and it was
considered that
if we went
we couldn't pass
[Music]
the
concerns
that i had but
if we put it through this committee
it
could um
take up
which is where we have it
because it was considered
foolish for
council to expose clear to criticism
by not treating her or her office as the
affected party
um and
it was um
the choice of the review person
that she
[Music]
would
lose that
feedback of impartiality
uh if we didn't do it through this
process
i think you worship um i'll move now to
councillor clark who has his hand up
thank you madam chair um just
on two issues that the mayor raises
i know that jane does work for the
office of the chief executive but as
councillor
ludlow has already suggested and he's
quite right there has been an impartial
look at this
i find it rather ironic that the
the mayor says that the chief executive
should not have any party to any review
or suggesting where the review is
because she is involved with this
but the mayor is also involved with this
he's the one that's making the
allegations yet he sits here today
giving his pennies worth so my view of
it is um
i know the chief executive took the
advice of the independent advisors that
we have and also bruce who's our
independent chair
of our risk and assurance committee and
the uh outcome that we've come to with
the terms of reference and the person's
going to do the review is a really good
outcome
and we shouldn't in any way uh go move
away from that it can give his mayor the
chance to have his say something totally
independent and away from right away
from the organizations
thank you
thank you councillor clark i think next
was council
thank you madam chair um as the mover of
these recommendations i just wanted to
say
and having considered them at risk and
assurance this morning also what we've
got is a very solid
set of recommendations high level
independently arrived at
and
i think with the
recommendation of a person to do the
review who has impeccable credentials
i've got no hesitation at all and saying
this is a healthy thing for council to
move forward with
and i don't understand
the mayor's hesitation on this
so i'm
very happy to have moved these
recommendations to go forward
thank you um councillor sofa was there
anyone else that wished to speak on
topic
no i'm seeing no hands or voices so um
yeah i mean
i'm mildly surprised by this process um
is his worship was actually part of
the resolutions that were made to allow
us access to the information so
naturally i'm
really quite surprised
that he is unaware considering he was
part of that process and to begin with
[Music]
now that there's no further discussion
uh i will put the four recommendations
that have the mover councillor leblo and
the second of councillor sopa
uh all those in favor
aye
aye
against no
uh would you like your vote recorded
your worship
uh vote recorded
thank you very much and our second item
that was urgent this afternoon was to
speak sorry um
alex can i just intervene just for the
benefit of the public that are watching
this live stream
the mayor today has voted twice against
this independent review and it might be
timely for me to ask him through this
process
what outcome is he actually looking for
given at this review
will
look into the complaints that he's made
against the organization and in
particular against the chief executive
so tim here's your chance to tell the
public you know if you're voting against
it what do you want as an alternative
well i would like to see an organization
where
issues like this are considered
to be
important for the smooth running of the
operation and that's
one of the reasons um i stood down on
uh
cheering the meeting because
i was involved in it myself so
i guess the issue is one of perception
as well that
if you're involved in an issue that
is a concern
you
can't um
expect
to win
support of
an unused no one else is facing
the kinds of um
difficulties
that that i'm facing
and i thought well
it would clear things up
for me to um explain why
i
i'm so concerned about
people going through
the um
process of
work which is
i don't think anyone would want
um
to have
unfortunately that doesn't actually
answer the question but um i'm sure that
this will run its course
um i'm not sure that you're going to get
an answer to your question uh councillor
clark
no matter how hard you try so
just i will make a reflection if you if
you give me the blessing of doing that
chair just just the mayor states that
he's he's the only one's being subject
to well
people with very short memories will
remember that i've been accused of
bullying them here i've been accused of
being brutus
of leaving affection or regime against
the mayor and i haven't jumped into the
media and bashed me around and i haven't
taken any other action when the mayor
raises a serious matter against the
chief executive we have no option but to
engage in independent progress process
which is what we're doing today the
issue will now be is will the mayor
engage with the
solicitor when he comes from wellington
because given that he's voted twice
against you you're a bit hypocritical to
then
jump in and give your pennies to it
i'll just leave it there anyway i think
people will leave it at that i mean um
thank you thank you for your time
i think
we'll leave it there i don't see us
getting to any kind of resolution at
this point it's just playing ping pong
um
and it's not really beneficial for any
of us
so um with that i'd just like to thank
the quality of the reporting that came
forward this afternoon as well and thank
you to all of the staff that have taken
the time to be here um
thank you to the public that have taken
the time to tune in um on to the live
stream and i appreciate that you all be
doing very well in your bubbles
um
and we'll now move into pe
to public excluded can i have a mover
for that
by way of explanation
um i
arrived here um
sort of late and
i i had to um
see a cat jumped on the bench and
knocked the computer to the ground and
and i had to
find another one
and i'd managed to do it didn't get here
one minute too but it was
frantically
um difficult
stated when i arrived at this meeting
today
notice um
you wish it
um it probably would have been best
stated uh
within the apologies portion of this
meeting but um
we'll let it slide
so we'll now move into uh pe for the
confirmation of minutes
uh for
the
public exclusive session of council held
on 27th of july for the public
experience session of the extraordinary
meeting of infrastructural services had
on the 27th of july
the public exclusive session of the
infrastructural services
meeting held on the 3rd of august and
the public excluding session of the
extraordinary council meeting held on
the 10th of august our major late item
and the reasons for heading into pe uh
is section 7.2 i which is to enable any
local authority holding information to
carry on without prejudice disadvantage
or negotiations
um
sorry prejudice or disadvantaged
negotiations including commercial and
industrial negotiations you can see um
all of those resolutions and the reasons
oh sorry
all of those subjects and the reasons
for why we're moving into public
excluded on the screen there
and also
our major lead item which was to discuss
the annual report and insurance renewal
that came forward from risk assurance
this morning
and that one is to enable
the insurance negotiations to continue
in the time frame it also relates to
section 7.2 i
i do believe that i had some people that
were jumping at the chance to put their
hand up
and have move it and second it for me so
if i could have those people put their
hands up again that would be
appreciated
thank you councillor munson and i can
see a big hand from council colinger
very enthusiastic
all those in favor
aye
against
i hear no noise for against so i'm going
to take that as carriage
thank you very much again to those that
are viewing today on
the live stream
and we'll now move into